Beta testing allows you to
assure the equality of your app,
by having real users actually use it.
As a startup without a quality assurance
team, it's great to build a community of
beta testers that can give you
the feedback you're looking for.
Let's hear from Amir Shavat about
what a beta testing community is,
and how to create them.
Amir's had a chance to start some
developer communities on behalf of
Google and is also the instructor
of Udacity's product course.
Beta Testing communities give you
insights you may miss about bugs in your
app or ways to improve your app
that you haven't thought of.
Now choosing your beta testing community
members or audience is really important.
There are a few things
you need to consider.
They must be representative
of the actual users that'll
be using your app when it launches.
For aBARKment, we should actually
find people who are dog owners, and
who are willing to let their
dogs go stay with a sitter.
They also have to be unbiased.
They can't have predetermined notions
about how they feel about the app
before experiencing it.
And of course, they must be willing to
give feedback and share their thoughts.
It'll be of no help to you if the beta
testers don't actually talk about
their experience.
The members of this community
should want to be a part of
the experience early on, and really
want to be a part of the creation and
improvement of your app.
Through beta testing,
you're going to have the opportunity
to learn a lot of things.
Such as,
does your app even do what should do?
Does your app crash or
does it have bugs?
Is your app too slow?
What do users think about your app?
How does your app look or
work on different types of devices?
And so much more.
So you'll need to think about how you
want to interact with your beta testing
community, because it
isn't only important for
them to be unbiased about the product,
you also need to be unbiased.
So how should you gather
this information from your
beta testing community.
Let's talk to Amir about that.
>> So first of all I don't think
you need to ask questions.
You need to observe behavior.
One of the key with beta testing is
that you get a lot of the data, and
rather than asking the questions,
you see how people behave with the app.
And that's super important.
Second, if you must ask questions,
you need to be very,
very sure that these are unbiased.
Like, asking things like,
is this a great app?
Will probably yield,
yes this is a great app.
Although it might not be a great app,
right?
Or, are you using it every day for
sure, will probably be a bad question.
So try to not prime the right answer,
your right answer.
So ask a question in
a very unbiased way.
>> So here are a few things you should
remember when interacting with your beta
testing community.
Observe behavior first.
You don't always need to ask questions.
You can just observe the behavior.
But when you do, be unbiased.
Don't ask leading questions to allow the
users to give room for honest response.
For more information on developing
questions for beta testing or
surveys in general, check out
the article in the instructor notes.
Another option is to create open beta
rather than a user testing community.
Google has a tool called Open beta.
You don't need to create a community
with this option to run your test.
You'll use Open beta when you want
any user with a link to your app
to be able to join your beta
test with just one click.
One of the major
advantages with open beta,
it allows you to scale
a large number of testers.
However, you can still limit
the maximum number of users you
want to join your beta test.
And finally, don't forget,
you need a collect data somehow.
As Amir said, beta testing without
collecting data is pointless.
You can set up a free Google Analytics
account to attach to your app.
It'll be able to track user behavior,
and provide you with reports on data
you're collecting, so
that you can make data driven decisions.
We'll dive deeper into
Google Analytics later on.